[Music]
it's not the first time benjamin
netanyahu has focused on israel's
palestinian citizens during an election
campaign
in 2015 he tried to boost right-wing
turnout
by warning of quote arabs coming to the
polls in droves
in 2019 facebook suspended a chatbot on
his account
which said arab politicians wanted to
quote annihilate us
all this time the message is very
different
a campaign video presents palestinian
israelis supporting a prime minister
who among other things is pledging to
address their number one
issue a surge
in violent crime sparking protests
against the israeli police
for failing to tackle it
i'm committed to bringing an end to the
violence and the crime in your
communities this is a national
assignment
it touches each and every one of you and
your children
in the northern city of haifa fadi is
reopening his restaurant after months of
kovid19
enforced closure for him netanyahu's
pitch is missing the mark
he's a hypocrite if we say this 20 times
it's not enough
they don't want any alliance with arabs
they never have
they'll never give us our rights
the same goes for the customers we spoke
to even those who've become frustrated
by the palestinian-israeli parliamentary
bloc
i'm not entirely happy with the air
parties because they haven't been
working properly
socially speaking things have been
deteriorating especially the violence
few expect benjamin netanyahu to
experience a sudden warm embrace from a
group of voters that he spent previous
elections
casting as a threat to the prospects of
a right-wing government
what he's looking for is just the
tiniest slice enough voters
to help him gain that extra one or two
seats that could prove crucial to his
chances
of forming a coalition for activists and
analyst jafar farah that means
improving on the 10 000 palestinian
israeli votes netanyahu's likud got last
time
of 660 000 votes cast more and more
arab voters actually support
uh the arab uh parties and less and less
support the
zionist parties so i don't expect really
big
uh support in netanyahu and the likud
but still he can gain potentially one to
two seats in our community
he may also benefit from a split in the
joint list palestinian-israeli grouping
the breakaway united arab list says it
may work with netanyahu after the
election
however that plays out one broader
change is emerging in recent polling
a growing acceptance of the political
legitimacy of a sector of society
for so long kept at arm's length harry
fawcett
al-jazeera haifa israel